the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so today we're going to analyze two
random algorithms we've seen in the last
lecture randomized the median and
randomized quicksort but before I go
into that so I'd like to make a
correction in problems that too I think
you all get feedback from that so it's
the second problem where you're asked to
combine B trees you have A to B trees t1
and t2 each with some children and we're
giving you a another element K and we
asked you to combine them so if they are
the two trees are of the same height how
do you do that does anyone want to share
his or her answer ok
yeah
yeah exactly so you put K here and if
this is to fool you split so why do I
have to do this can I simply just make
pay my new route and do this
yeah exactly so for b-tree the
requirement on route it's slightly
different for from the requirements for
the rest of the notes so this may have
too few children it is not a valid note
it's not a valid internal node but this
our solution actually made a mistake in
the second part in the second part we're
saying so t1 and t2 their heights are
different by one our solutions ask put K
here and make a pointer the exact is
exactly the same problem does everyone
see that this may not be a valid
internal node so what's the correct
solution you put K here and combine it
with the last child of t1 and then you
may have to split ends video again hey
happy with that
okay now today we are going to look into
randomization specifically we have seen
two algorithm in class I'll just go down
quick fine and quicksort
so quickfind is a slightly generalized
version of median finding in the very
first lecture and recitation we have
seen a long randomized version of
quicksort so we divide them into groups
of five and we find a medium of each
group and then find a medium of the
median depending on whether you are
smaller or larger we do a funny
subproblem like this and you're gonna
remember that and we analyze this run
time where it bcurtin there's 1/5 plus
some 7 over 10 or something like that
and we show its worst case o of n so
that's a smart algorithm I'll give you
that but it's just complicated you have
to divide them into groups and do well
several recursive course and also let me
digress a little bit there is a very
interesting point regarding this worst
case or worst case of an algorithm has
anyone wondered why we use groups of 5
why not groups of 3
algorithm should work in the same way if
we take out this first row and this last
row we can still find the medium which
is just a second element in each group
and find the median the median we still
have a subproblem look that look like
this exercise and it turns out if we use
groups of three when we solve the
recursion it doesn't solve 200 then it's
off to something else okay now end up
that question let's get back to the
randomized diversion so how does the
randomized version work is that much
simpler we have an array let me call it
find in an array a which which is of
size n and we want to find a largest or
smallest element in it so what we're
going to do is that we'll pick a random
element X in this array and then we'll
put all the smaller elements smaller
elements on this side and all the larger
elements on that side
now because I'm picking a random one so
this X can be anywhere if it is the case
smallest element from the left then what
do I do next
my goal is to find a knife smallest
element in this array a
okay if it's if I is less than K then my
element is on this side right so I
should find okay let me define this to
be the left all right this would be the
right array I should find in the left
array what is it sighs its K minus 1
make sense this is K minus 1 and that is
n minus k plus 1 admony in the middle so
what's the last argument in that
function call sigh so on the other hand
if I is greater than k then I should go
to my right car this problem size is n
minus K so what's the last argument
hi
agree
I'm minus K okay so of course if I zero
then k then we just return X now
obviously this algorithms runtime
depends on our lock depends on this
choice of K if K is roughly in the
middle then we reduce the problem size
by roughly half right however if K is 0
or close to n then we only reduce the
problem satisfy a little bit so it's
it's impossible to give a definite
runtime so what we up to do in random in
randomized algorithm is that we analyze
expected runtime what does that mean
so we can write the recursion of this
steel then equals
I have two sub-problems one of them is T
of K minus-1 the other is T of n minus K
so which one is should I put into the
recursion
yeah I don't know right but I don't know
whether my element is in on the left or
on the right so I'll be conservative and
take a max of these two let me write it
down it
and I have some amount of work to do
before I go to the my sub-problem what's
the what's the complexity of that of
that work it's all then yeah oh dear I
am what why is that
yes because we have to scan the array
once to put the smaller elements on one
side and larger elements on the other
side now this big recurrence is
impossible to solve because I don't know
what K is so instead we'll just
calculate its expectation
so the expectation of T of n is taking
average over all the randomness which
means the choice of K I so there is a
probability that my K is equal to okay
if my K is equal to J then I should take
the maximum of sorry
right if my K is equal to j then I
should take the expectation of the
maximum between putting those two and
according to the definition fix
expectation I should do a sum from J
equals zero
no not zero I'm starting with with 1 all
the way to and right any questions so
far
now obviously
depending on my choice of Jay sometimes
this one is larger sometimes that one is
larger
I'll just write it a little verbose Lee
so if my J is 1 then I should take the
right one plus if j j is 2 then I should
take a minus 2 so on and so forth right
I think everyone's gets this right so I
just directly jump to the next step
so when J is smaller than half of them I
will take the right one if J is larger
than Carter then I will take the left
one and they happen to be a symmetric
they happen to be symmetric and what I
have here is
now maybe I'm missing the minus one here
okay I should end some two there I have
n minus 1 and minus 2 and minus 3 all
the way to Harper then but from there I
no longer go down right I go backwards
half of n plus 1 plus 2 plus 3 all the
way back to n minus 1 in question so far
oh I we forgot our last term which is a
theta n
how do we solve this
any any boss
this is a recurrence on the expectation
of T so for this general this type of
general recurred recurrence we don't
have a very good way instead what we'll
do is just take random guess and then
see if it if it's correct okay so I
don't need to guess in this case because
I know it's all then so let's just
assume our expectation of TN is Theta of
n what does that mean again
it means I can find some constant such
that if this is expectation is bounded
by a constant times n so far so good now
we can use induction assume that this
holds for everything up to n minus 1 and
we're going to show this also holds for
n then we are done thing now we'll just
plug that in and the expectation of TN
will be less or equal than this son from
above n - n
right
I just plug that in cause closet either
enter now what's the sum of this guy
and you guys
and square thank you Oh N okay it's
probably a little messy and more cleanly
I can put this P out it's just a sigma
of J if I change my some decrease the
range of Sun by one what is the Sigma
sum of J on what order first and square
okay definitely n square we need to be a
little bit more precise than that so
what's the coefficient before the n
square
so I claim this coefficient is 3 over 8
and you must see that oh that's a that's
just a guess if it's wrong we'll have to
assume something else which we will see
in the next example a good question
ok ah yeah let me ask the question again
I claim this son is roughly 3 over 8 and
square and anyone see that
any ideas
so I don't know how to calculate this
term but I do know how to calculate
Sigma from 1 to N right this is easy
right
what's that it's other than n minus 1
right so it's roughly it's roughly half
of the N square now my this this term is
the sum of this minus the sum to harder
right so it's roughly
so it's roughly half of n square minus
1/2 of 1/2 n square make sense so this
is roughly 3 over 8 and square plus an
order enter or less or constant and
questions does that make sense yeah then
it's very easy if we just plug this
thing okay hmm sorry there is a mistake
I just realized and anyone pointed out
so how many times do I have in toto
one for men well I'll have any time
right so each term should appear twice
right yeah so I should have a two here
and so I somehow just throw away this
probability but this probability is 1
over N right because I'm choosing a
random element there is 1 over N
probability that is equal to 1 equal to
2/3 for everyone every of those every of
this is 1 over n correct
so I should have a - over in here - over
in here and if we plug this in its three
over eight and cube plus the theta our
goal is to show this is less than P
times n which is clearly true because
this is 3/4 of n 3/4 B times n plus
another term we can we can say this is
another constant and D times n and if we
choose B accordingly this can hold any
questions
you look confused or too easy okay I
guess it's the latter
are they not
okay so then we have solved this
expected runtime of quick pint now let's
look at quicksort
quicksort
is very similar the only difference is
that once I arrived at once I put all
the smaller elements on one side and
larger elements on the other side
instead of going into one of them I have
to sort both so the only change is that
instead of taking a max here I need to
add them
correct
so now same thing here instead of taking
the max I should add them up now when it
propagates here so every term appears
twice all the way from N equals one to J
equals 1 to J equals n is that one
following
I know
okay sure originally we have an axe here
right so yeah first did everyone get
this part we have a plus instead of max
here I think you have to solve both the
problems now it is a max then what I
have is minus 1 and minus 2 all the way
to half of N and then half of n half of
N plus 1 all the way back to n minus 1
right and if I have a son then what I
have is for the for J equals ones case I
have P of 0 and T of n minus 1 right
this is J equals 1 if K equals 2 I have
T of 1 and T of n minus 2 I as J
increases this one goes from 0 to N and
this one goes from n minus 1 to 0 I'm
going to sum all of them up
does that answer your question
okay so instead of from hop Evangeline
we are summing from 1 to M now we also
have another good question here why do I
guess
is Theta well it's just a random guess
it could be wrong for example in this
case it's just incorrect why because
every sum becomes the range becomes a 1
to n now what I have is no longer 3 over
8 okay what do I have again what do I
have now
it is 1 over
yeah it's one harder than but if I
change one half here what I get is B
times n plus P times n I'm want to prove
that is smaller than B times n which is
clearly impossible no matter how you
choose B
did everyone got that
if we make the same assumption I'll make
the hypothesis and we plug the mean we
can no longer prove the induction step
okay so what do we do we make another
guess so let me rewrite our recursion
what's the next guest
and because it
and it's just guys how about we just
goes in square
okay anyone happy with that I'm happy
with that guess so we can do the same
thing we can plug it in and that will be
uh sorry I miss it another time right
this is a 1 over N what 1 over 2 here if
we make that gas than what we have is a
Sun from 1 to n minus 1 the sum of J
square velocity data and the sum of J
square is roughly
and cube divided by three is that his is
the lobbyists everyone maybe not okay
okay can anyone explain this to us why
can I claim the sum of square term is a
thank you
over three
go ahead mmm
and
I think you're correct there is a
formula which is yeah I don't remember
exactly but it's roughly roughly this
right if you know this then you
definitely see that if you don't this we
can we can turn this son into an
integral alright and that is and killed
over three make sense now if we plug
that in what do we have 2 over n 3 n
cube plus theta n of course there is a B
here and we want to show this is less
than B times n square
as a whole is it true
it's clearly show right so this is no
this is cute
yeah sorry I'm making many mistakes but
that's actually good to catch your
attention but it actually worries me
that you didn't point this out this is
two thirds and square times P is clearly
less than P and square okay so we
claimed the algorithm is n square
exactly so what I proved here is that
the algorithm is definitely order n
square but maybe less right and you can
see we still have a lot of room here
this inequality doesn't is not very
tight so in fact it's a very good good
question how do we make that guess so
if this you already know the answer is n
log n right so it's not interesting but
if you don't then how do we go about and
do things we can we have to make these
guesses so how about we know is n
doesn't hold and 2 is too much let's get
this n raised to 1 plus epsilon then
we'll what we have if we carry out the
same integral argument we have 2 plus
epsilon and raise to 2 plus if snow over
to precision all correct and if we plug
that in
we got this we want to show it's less
than n raise to 1 plus if snow that's
this whole this term is less than 1 and
that's n raise to 1 plus Epsilon
so this is true so we can easily prove
its indeed n raise to 1 plus if snow and
for any if so no questions
but is it tight we still don't know so
then what do we do we just make another
guess and let's guess here then using
order n log N
okay you definitely you may run into two
two cases you can either prove it or not
if if this doesn't hold you just go to
the login square and gradually you will
find the answer well if you don't know
the answer probably this is how you do
things now if we guess is n log n then I
have a little harder equation here
because it's now jail object
how do i compute that
it's not the sum of natural number horn
amps or squares of numbers so you cannot
use like formula like this but we can
still use the integral argument right
I'm not going to do that because that's
what you should have learned in calculus
or other math class but it happens that
this integral of J log J is roughly half
of N squared log n minus some constant
times log n I think you can change this
constant but it's roughly smaller than
that if you plug that in you get
and over to 1/2 times be
Plus see the N and we want to we want it
to be smaller than B times n log n which
will be true
because you can yeah this is exactly
that and but we are - some time and the
time we are extracting is larger than
the data enter ok so we can prove this
algorithm is n log n but you can ask the
same question how do I know is n log n
oh if I don't know it's n log n maybe I
should go about and try log log n so
you're welcome to try and it's actually
a very good thought
because yeah I I think it's very
uninteresting if you already know the
answer if you don't know you have to try
that but when do you stop at a
reasonable point you can also prove the
other way that is run time is larger
than something here if you we prove this
Big O of n log n if you can show the
other way that is Omega n log n then you
know you have arrived at a final answer
okay that's the Mac part any questions
about that yeah any questions about
everything I have said so far
but not also lastly just a few comments
several terminology now this recitation
we focused on expected runtime you have
always you have already seen amortize
the runtime or you may have heard of
average runtime so to be honest expect
it and amortized are just too fancier
ways of saying average but in our burden
analysis we do mean slightly different
things with these terms so the
difference is that we are averaging over
different things so if we say average
runtime we usually mean taking an
average over input we can imagine a
quicksort or click find algorithm that
doesn't use randomness where you always
select your first an element as your
pivot that's a reasonable algorithm if
your input is random then you can carry
out the same argument and show that its
complexities or then or n log n but if
your input is pre-sorted or reverse
solid in some special cases you cannot
do that so average runtime is usually a
very weak argument because you have to
make assumptions about your input and
expected runtime is definitely better
because we are taking average over the
randomness we introduced it's if they
are independent of the input so we are
not making any assumptions on the input
so of course this comes at a price this
randomness doesn't come for free so in
fact it's very hard to generate high
quantity random numbers and maybe at the
end of the class you will see that in
crypto a lot of the a lot of works are
just devoted to generate high-quality
random numbers if you can do that
efficiently
solve a lot of problems so advertise the
runtime slightly again different from
these two because they are taking
average over the number of operations
it's you're doing many many operations
in a row and some of them takes longer
some of them take shoulder and you take
average on those okay that's today's
recitation any questions